foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi please Morgan uncensored tonight is
snow woke and the Seven diversity hires
Disney stirs outrage by abolishing the
dwarfs and his physically sensitive
remake of the fairy tale classy is it
time to stand up for the little guys
against diversity obsessed Hollywood
will debate plus records are smashed as
heat waves spark wildfires and deadly
temperatures across the globe Skeptics
call it climate alarmism but should we
be genuinely alarmed we'll debate and
we're live in Death Valley
sweltering heat to cool as ice active
business Mogul and rap Legend Ice Cube
goes uncensored with me one-on-one
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London and welcome to
Facebook and uncensored I've always used
this show as a platform to stand up for
the little guys never before have I
meant that quite so literally as I do
tonight behind the scenes pictures from
Disney's live-action remaker Snow White
release this weekend there appears to be
a sizable problem where are the Dwarfs
they're gone canceled banished and not
this time by the wicked Queen are they
bitten the poison apple of diversity and
inclusion which has turned out to
exclude them Disney's PC reimagining of
the legendary fairy tale doesn't feature
seven dwarves at all instead it's seven
magical creatures of varying sizes
shapes ethnicities and agendas the lead
role of Snow White is played by Hispanic
actress Rachel zegler and I've got no
real issue with that although of course
Snow White was called Snow White because
her skin was as white as the snow and
that was of course in a fairy tale we've
been lectured for years about cultural
appropriation and the vital importance
of Hispanics playing Hispanics trans
actors the trans characters disabled
stars or disabled Parts but where's the
consistency in the original fairy tale
the brothers Grim wrote that Snow White
is called Snow White because as I say a
skin was Snow White that's why her
mother called her Snow White
and that's the problem when you start
pandering to the permanently offended
you can never go far enough last year
Peter Dinklage probably the most famous
dwarf in the world slammed Disney for
including dwarves in its movie at all
you're still telling the story of Snow
White yeah Seven Dwarfs sure look take a
step back and look at what you're doing
there yeah I know that's it makes no
sense to me well oh so you're
Progressive in one way and then but
you're still making that backward oh
story about seven dwarves living in a
cave to get what the are you doing
well Peter Dixon's got his way the duels
have now been sidelined canceled as
critics in the dwarf Community pointed
out though it's all well and good for
Peter Dinklage to take this moralizing
stand now he's already made millions of
dollars and become a mega Star by
playing a dwarf in shows like Game of
Thrones Disney for its part so just
taking a different approach to avoid
reinforcing stereotypes but what exactly
are the stereotypes in Snow White that
are so problematic the Seven Dwarves
your Miracle are industrious inventive
friendly and yes they're small what's
wrong with any of that
or stereotypical what's damaging what's
harmful
and then another blow for diminutive
actors trailers for the new Willy Wonka
movie Reveal something really quite
sinister
you're the funny little man who's been
following me I will have you know that I
am a perfectly respectable size foreign
that's right regular-sized irritant Hugh
Grant has taken a plant role as one of
Wonka's pint-sized assistance again
depriving a talented dwarf Act of a role
he's born to play and that's the problem
with you grant never cares about the
little guys well joining me is Dylan
posal who played Hornswoggle the
leprechaun in WWE between 2006 and 2016
and by the podcaster and commentator
James Barr all right uh James you've got
a no problem with what Disney are doing
you think this is Progressive and
inclusive and all those moaning about it
should shut up I think you should live
in the 1930s actually peers because
that's where you belong really listening
to what you were just saying then also
I'm going to quote Warwick Davis because
he said he finds it patronizing when
people are offended on his behalf and
you've just spent a five minute
monologue being offended on his behalf
and I think that's ridiculous well let
me bring in Dylan because Dylan uh is
also offended and he happens to be a
dwarf actor Dylan I've got to say I I
was very curious when I saw what Peter
Dinklage came out and said because I did
wonder who appointed him the head of the
dwarfactor community and it turns out
nobody rather than him and the people
who it seems to me have really suffered
in all this are the six dwarf actors who
would have expected to have roles in
this remake in a massive Hollywood
Blockbuster who are now not going to
have that experience all the money all
the fame that may have come with it what
is your response to that
so it's not a progression at all to me
my issue with it is exactly what you
said there are actors dwarf actors that
live that dream to be in a major Motion
Picture such as this Disney remake and
now because Peter Dinklage said what he
said last year
now it's taken away and it's taken away
because of quote unquote progression and
all that that's it's not it's not really
it's not right because these are roles
made for actors of my stature roles that
aren't ever really given I can't go out
for the Harrison Ford or the George
Clooney roles because that's not for me
these dwarf roles are for people of my
stature right and now it's taken away
it I don't feel that's right and not
only that but now think about the
additional stunt actors or body doubles
or that now you're talking multiple
actors right of my stature that don't
get these major roles and why what's the
real what's the reasoning because we're
supposed to be Progressive and we're
supposed to just not view them as that
well you know the other heroes are these
dwarves
all of these dwarves took care of Snow
White they all had characteristics
separate characteristics they weren't
these cave dwelling monsters that that
people speak of it's It's they all had
seven different characteristics for
seven different actors that from my
community and I don't I don't feel it's
right that they got taken completely and
utterly agree with you and the irony is
that they profess these progressives to
want to do this to protect you right
they protect dwarf actors from being you
know somehow smeared but you don't feel
that way at all Peter
Peter Dinklage spoke up about this and
that was my issue he had in the past no
issue cashing checks that were made for
dwarf rolls like elf and all of that yes
he blew away the barriers when he did
his his roles that weren't necessarily
made for a dwarf but
the elf roll was made for a dwarf that
check cleared just fine so now that he's
gone and done that the progression of
dwarf actors he's he it just doesn't it
doesn't sit right with me this guy who
is exactly what you said what what gave
him the voice for all of our community
I completely hypocrite let me bring Joe
let me bring James back in Japanese
Morgan is agreeing with you I think you
need to be concerned I'll say that for
the so you're telling the Dual fact to
what he should say hang on having
literally just lectured me about
speaking for someone in the dwarf
Community Warwick Davis you now accuse a
dwarf I'm not no it's not what I said I
said that if anyone if you're siding
with anyone you've got to worry what I'd
like to say actually is that I kind of
mostly agree with what you're saying now
you're it's
sorry that's just taking a pot shot
there no saying oh yeah
but I do agree with what you're saying I
completely agree with your point of view
and I think that's really important but
I I can only speak from my experience
and as a gay man I know that growing up
I witnessed gay people being villains in
movies when I was seven dwarves are
villains and that I think stereotypes
are really important too what
stereotypes in the universe of Snow
White wouldn't it be I don't feel it
this isn't a part of this about The
Stereotype right this is about roles
that were that were made for people such
of my stature that don't have the chance
to go out for other roles normally but
you James so why you you want to stop
Dylan
I'm not going to get into an attack you
don't want a dual factor I do a dwarf
part listen a dwarf can play a dwarf
part but I think it's important to
change narratives that don't fit in
today's society and really which is that
narrative it might be better
normal roles everywhere because they do
what was so bad about the way dwarves
were depicted in Snow White have I
missed something well that listen I'm
not that's right that's what I'm kind of
wondering is I don't represent Disney
but I'm just saying I think I see their
point of view what's their point of view
what was so bad about the depiction of
this why are you so upset about a movie
changing with the times and moving
forward because I think honestly there
is real news we could be discussing no
but this is real news if you're a dwarf
actor who are not out of work because of
virtue signaling idiots but you're just
using this everything has to be reread
you want you to be inclusive it's not
inclusive at all no you're using Dylan
as a cheap shot to attack a wokie that's
I don't think Dylan feels I'm using him
as a cheap shot and what I would say
about the wokie thing is this I have
spent the last year listening to people
tell me only gay actors should play gay
Parts only Welsh actress of Michael
Sheen should play Welsh characters and
so on and so on but the moment we have
dwarf roles which are the most famous
dwarf roles in Hollywood history then
the only people apparently you can't
play them are dwarf actors and I see
there it's a cartoon King here it has
not changed it was a cartoon those
weren't actually dwarfs in the movie
they were drawn okay so firstly they
were drawn as dwarfs no that is
dwarves
they shouldn't be cool doors no they
should be called people with this what's
wrong with me
that's the story
apparently Dylan you're not allowed to
call yourself dwarves apparently
I would love to hear what should I call
myself sir I think you should call
yourself whatever you feel comfortable
with but as a person he calls himself
good for you I'm happy so that so now
but now sir let me let me let me pause
that
so we it shouldn't be called Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs
because I think your point of view is
more important than mine right now but
what I'm annoyed about is peers trying
to take a cheap shot at someone that
believes in society moving forward yeah
I'm actually really if I'm actually
exposing the hypocrisy of the woke
mentality of only gay people can play
gay Parts only trans actors can play
trans Parts until I think we took a
place
on the Seven Dwarves has to be canceled
because you're not allowed to have
dwarfs you should be happy peers because
it means that now you can play your
dream role of grumpy I would love to
play grumpy I loved all the dwarves in
that movie they were great being a
hypocrite you'd love to play Crosby but
you're taking a wrong way the issue at
hand no I would play a fully grown Grump
quite happily taking away a role from
let me ask you Dylan about the Hugh
Grant playing an Oompa Loompa because
again it seems to me we've got a clip of
him playing let's have a look at this
funny little man who's been following me
I will have you know that I am a
perfectly respectable size foreign
now they use CGI there Dylan to
effectively make him into an Oompa
Loompa so now what do you feel about
that yes sir so now
now we're not only
using CGI and spending extra money and
funding for these movies when we could
just cast dwarves in that role whether
it be one dwarf or multiple that like
they have been in the past now you're
taking at least one roll away or
multiple rolls away for Oompa Loompa
characters that that's what they were in
the past and and why again I go back to
my my stance on
these roles roles in Hollywood in
general are very hard for people of my
community to get besides the elf and the
leprechaun and this and that so why are
they being taken from my community
that's my issue here well you know what
you know watching us stereotypes you
know why because people like James here
they think it's Progressive and
inclusive now well in fact it's
regressive it's regressive and exclusive
Pierce I
Dylan Pierce I will I I will I will
agree with the mindset of it's not right
uh I don't know James James seems to be
in in partial agreeance with me on the
dwarf actors and the roles with that
that these should be but I I don't on
the other stuff I can't speak on that
obviously it's that's I'm focused fully
on the dwarf Community really losing
roles in these films I think James
starts with James strikes with all that
with all the writer strikes
I do agree with you and I think all I'm
trying to say is that I think it's a
nuanced conversation and there's a few
different points of view that are valid
and ultimately in my experience as a gay
man the reason we're upset about gay
people not getting gay roles in movies
is because we're not getting straight
roles as well and until we are it's
unfair that those roles are taken away
from us so with in that respect what's
that got to do with more patches they
can't play regular size I think Peter
dinklish's original point is that he
would like to see more dwarves in films
in general not just playing dwarfs
literally I should a person of my
stature should be able to go out for the
same as a six foot five two hundred
pound human but it's it's just not that
way and I'm okay with that in reality
I'm okay with that it's understandable
to me but when it's these roles that are
made for people of myself yes that's
where I have the issue you know what
Dylan the movie one of the great movies
of all time it's called Snow White and
the Seven Dwarfs if if dwarf actors in
Hollywood are not picked to play those
roles I don't know what roles you're
supposed to be playing it's it's
unbelievably I have patronizing they've
done this under the banner of so-called
progression
and it's not again like I said these
dwarves in that movie and or in this
this uh story aren't viewed poorly I
don't believe they're all separate
characters that are actually Heroes for
this lady yes and they take care and
they take this lady in they say reviewed
so well to society they saved the woman
now they're hard working they're wealthy
they they are kind they are generous
hearted it's hard to think of a more
positive sort of goal narrative about
any people at all well let's just go
back to the 1930s peers I think you'd be
happy you know what James face would
exist no no no no it's not blackface
it's James it's not blackface
because you know you've lost your spirit
I know you've lost the argument no
there's no argument you know you've been
here
hold on hold on guys we agree with each
other please all right you know what you
do agree with him now because you
realize the futility of your argument
James you can't go and go oh you gotta
go back to 1930s no James when you if
you agree with what I'm saying I agree
with what you're saying I don't agree
with anything that peers yeah here's the
thing Dylan Dylan just to be clear he
literally just said well I said James
Dylan just to be clear he doesn't agree
when I say it but when you say it he
agrees that right now I'm not a dwarf no
but that right there is the hypocrisy of
the white Brigade uh okay okay so let me
let me just say did I gotta let go
unfortunately please Pierce Pierce wrote
James James let me ask you this so if if
a writer writes a piece on what I'm
saying is it wrong of them because
essentially that's the same as the words
coming out of my mouth what yeah but
you're not saying that I am a woke
hypocrite and peers is and that's what I
disagree with because I'm absolutely not
I
he disagrees with what I say but when
you say exactly the same thing he
completely agrees with it James Barr
right to a tea nonsense fantastic having
you on Piers Morgan uncensored you did
such a brilliant job in highlighting why
this is so ridiculous shame on Disney
and I hope you get another brilliant
role very soon I really do
well I I hope so too and I I hope that
uh this really kind of resounds with how
my how I feel yeah and I don't speak for
the whole dwarf culture and and
Community but this is
thank all of you thank you for joining
me and James that's helpful thank you
for joining me because it's so well you
came on and you beautifully highlighted
the The Hip Hop hypocrisy culture of
your culture absolutely uncensored next
temperature records tumble as a deadly
Heat Wave Sparks wildfires and warnings
to stay indoors albeit not in the UK
Death Valley could be about to register
the hottest temperature ever recorded on
planet Earth we're live there next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
weekend of deadly temperatures across
parts of Asia Europe and North America
meteorologists are expecting more
record-breaking temperatures in the next
few days in China this weekend
temperatures hit 52.2 degrees Celsius in
Italy temperatures could surpass 46
degrees Celsius by next Sunday and in
the USA after a weekend high of 53 some
experts reckon Death Valley could maybe
as soon as today register the highest
temperature recorded on earth so is it
another freak weather event or is it the
Red Alert Skeptics may need to look up
and acknowledge the immediate relatives
of climate change what I mean northern
Sweden you also invest things first I
remember probably to say on climate
change Bjorn Lombard in Washington
atmospheric meteorologist Matthew
capucci the first let's go live to Gio
Ponce is a park ranger at Death Valley
which may well break all-time records
maybe even as early as today uh well
welcome uh to you Jim what's it like
today how does it feel this kind of heat
uh it's pretty warm so uh forecasted
highs today are supposed to be 125
degrees Fahrenheit which is about 53 or
so
um definitely normal for this time of
year uh but we are having an excessive
heat warning all week long uh any
visitors to the park should definitely
take precautions what is interesting is
we're now seeing those temperatures in
China we're seeing them in parts of
Europe nearly at that level as well what
does that tell you about what may be
going on with our climate
uh we might see some impacts uh here in
Death Valley we're definitely seeing
some impacts I mean seven of death
Valley's hottest Summers occurred in
just the last 10 years and it's only
predicted to get higher we're seeing
impacts in our wildlife in our
vegetation uh Bristlecone pine trees we
do have them here in Death Valley and
they're starting to see the effects as
well
so really tangible things that you can
see now on an almost annual basis and
getting worse are you fearful about what
may be coming
uh we're definitely concerned and we're
definitely trying to take steps to
address them uh trying to plan ahead for
the future uh seeing as we're protecting
Death Valley for future Generations
um but yeah it's definitely concerning
and there are lots of people coming as
tourists to Death Valley purely to
experience the heat is that a sensible
idea
um well uh it's definitely possible to
visit death valley during the hottest
times of the summer we just urge people
to do so safely uh now Death Valley is
one of the largest national parks in the
lower 48 states where 3.4 million Acres
large we're roughly the size of the
state of Connecticut were larger than a
few European countries so it's a big
park lots of big Wilderness spaces and
all we ask of visitors if you're going
to come you definitely want to just
drive around to the popular viewpoints
stick to the paved roads and stick close
to your air-conditioned car it's really
important to limit outdoor exposure you
just want to make sure that you're
staying hydrated and wearing all sorts
of sun protection I appreciate you
taking time out from what must be a busy
time for you thank you very much indeed
thank you Jim Ponce there is a warden
done at Death Valley which could
literally kill you in these Heats
um let's go now to uh Matthew Capuchin
you're an atmospheric meteorologist
Matthew what does this tell you we're
here there's seven in the last 10 years
record-breaking levels of heat in Death
Valley alone we're now seeing obviously
China many parts of Europe having record
highs
what do you put this down to is there
any other explanation than climate
change
well most definitely it's not really one
or the other weather is always going to
happen we'll have ups and downs and
random extreme events because whether
after all is just kind of the average
the sum of a bunch of different press
and drops that said we have a background
of human induced climate change raising
the floor and sort of nudging events
exceptional events into record territory
imagine for example that I want to be a
basketball player I'm not a super tall
person once in a great while I might
randomly get a Leia but if suddenly the
floor of that basketball court keeps
rising and Rising a little bit the odds
of me getting a layup or a slam dunk go
up and up and up so the same thing is
happening here yes it's summertime yes
it's hot but we're pushing these heat
domes these big sprawling blobs of high
pressure and hot air into record
territory so these kind of exceptional
events will happen much more often okay
uh Bjorn lomberg you're a climate
skeptic climate change skeptic why we're
giving all this apparent evidence that
the planet is literally overheating
so Peterson thanks uh first of all I
think Matt and I are totally in
agreement Global warning's real and as
temperatures rise you're going to see
more heat waves that's not what I'm
skeptical about as the implications that
we're being told so one is that means we
should start implementing policies as
essentially dissembled the entire growth
Machinery of the last 200 years so it's
going to cost hundreds of trillions of
dollars and they'll have absolutely no
impact over the next couple of decades
no if you actually want to help people
and you need to help people with heat
you need more air conditioning you need
cheap energy you need more climate
resilient cities and then you also need
to recognize that while heat is
certainly dangerous it still is only
about one-tenth as dangerous as cold
around the world and so if you really
care about saving human lives you need
to recognize those temperatures rise
you're going to see more heat waste
that's a problem you're also going to
see fewer cold waves which is great and
actually saves more people right now so
again we need to recognize yes there is
a problem but it's not the solution that
we're normally told how much of this
problem do you believe is man-made that
we could avoid if we change our
behavioral patterns
so again I'm I'm a social scientist so I
simply buy into what the U.N climate
panel tells us it's somewhere between 50
and 100 caused by human beings so we are
the main reason for this we need to fix
this in the long run absolutely and we
do that through Innovation that's how we
solve most problems in the world but we
do not do it by making enormous promises
that we're not actually going to keep
spending hundreds of trillions of
dollars and not actually helping the
people who are affected by heat right
now the way you do that is by making
climate resilient cities by making them
cooler you paint the rooftops white you
make more uh White areas you make more
Greenery and then you make energy so
cheap that people can actually afford to
keep both their air conditioning running
in the summer but also their heating
running in the winter the heating that
kills 10 times as many people as as heat
waves does some people may listen to
that and say okay but aren't you just
effectively pulling a Nero you're not
just fiddling while the World Burns
I don't think I'm I'm not even sure what
pulling an era means but it
time to say is we need to do stuff that
actually help people I thought if you
think back in France in 2003 there's a
huge Heat Wave uh it killed probably uh
000 people in in Paris France almost all
politicians said the way we're going to
fix that is by implementing the Kyoto
Protocol no that will help nothing it'll
still mean it'll get warmer but slightly
less warmer towards the end of the
century that's ridiculous the way you
should help these elderly people in the
next Generations of elderly people is by
making sure you have air conditioning in
Elderly Homes and that's indeed what
France had so when they had much higher
heat waves many fewer people died that's
how you actually help people yes we
should also fix climate change in the
long run but smartly not stupid okay
Bill Lombard uh and Matthew thank you
both very much indeed on a sense of next
after all that heat time to cool down
I'll be talking to rapper actor and
business Mogul Ice Cube join me after
the break for an interesting interview
with a fascinating guy
[Music]
yeah
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on Special
Edition from Canada tonight a special
edition of Piers Morgan uncensored
Martinez he's making me cry again do you
believe you can win this war so are you
gonna run again I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy yes I feel
betrayed they're trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around well these
protesting just don't get it many of
them don't it's not slightly patronizing
I would call him
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments I'd be there for weeks did
you keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bean
all about this where are they where's
their children
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him you're sure
your shape is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
foreign
[Laughter]
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
I think it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
is your favorite nickname that Trump's
giving us Rhonda sanctimonious or
meatball Rock I've seen you clown Tommy
Fury so please go easy on me bro please
go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the truth if you had to
come up against a team and had a Russian
player would you shake that your chance
she said well I've only got two years
and I said you'll have two months if you
carry on like this what's your response
to him the whole nation deserves to know
what happened you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan on sensed
Ice Cube is a hip-hop Superstar tone
actor whoever since joining the group
NWA has never been afraid of stirring
controversy with his words well he sat
down with me in New York last week to
talk politics money and how he responded
when yay Kanye West accused of inspiring
his anti-semitic outbursts
and I'm joined Now by Ice Cube or Ice
Cube thank you so much for joining me
thanks for having me great to have you
it's good to be here a Bonafide a legend
ah thank you thank you you let me call a
legend uh
that's cool you know uh it's it's cool
it's it's interesting because I'm still
you know here and I'm I still feel like
I got so much to do so
um it's nice let me ask you this there's
been a lot of stuff uh about the state
of the world about the state of America
what do you see things right now
I think um
I think you know
people are very polarized in all kind of
ways uh people are
afraid to speak out
because of the cancer culture Council I
said cancer cancel culture that we have
today so I just think you know people
are
afraid and they're running to their
Corners you know in a way it is a cancer
cancer
it behaves like that it does because it
makes not only the person that's getting
canceled
uh they're trying to shut them up but
anybody's watching now they shut up
because they say if it can happen to
this guy it can happen to me so by by
Smashing somebody who says something
that you might not like and canceling
them
it actually reverberates throughout the
whole community and everybody now
is watching what they say all the time
see what's the answer to this because I
think it's crazy in a democracy like the
United States like United Kingdom the
people are too frightened to speak their
mind to say what they think what do we
do about this I think you say what you
want to say
and to hell with the consequences you
got to be willing to fight for your
rights and fight for what you believe in
and if you're a person who believes in
freedom of speech you have to fight
and say what you feel and let chips fall
where they may and uh stand on that and
you know it may not be an easy road but
um I think you feel better about
yourself when you say what needs to be
said at the time it needs to be said and
not afterwards where you go home and
think I should have said this
when that guy was there or when I was
there I should have said that and I
didn't that haunts you more you can
definitely say what the hell you like on
this show it's called it's called
uncensored well that's why I'm here man
you know that even we've been on citizen
um let me ask you this
is America
more racist or less racist than when you
were a kid
I think it's pretty much the same
because it's uh it's institutionalized
and
you know the institution takes on
different
faces so to speak uh but
you know I don't know if the if racism
in the financial sector or has gotten
any better
um
we still
have a hard time getting Capital when we
need it we still have a hard time
um having that access to to those you
know currency streams that's out there
um and and so it affects us in the same
way in 1865
black people on
um
maybe one or two percent of America
um and I believe we're still in that
same place is that right yeah it's
barely changed the last rapper that I
interviewed in this very Studio was
yay Kanye West yeah uh you've had a
wobbly relationship with him because
you're back on track I read that you you
saw him in fact a few days ago yeah a
couple weeks ago uh I mean we were
always cool you know he just he spoke my
name without really explaining what he
meant and I and I just really couldn't
leave that statement out there without
you know he never explained what he
meant and so I had to you know kind of
rebut that but since then we've talked
and I think I think yay understands that
generalizing
will will always get you in
in more hot water than being very
specific
you know because I haven't really seen
much of it since I interviewed him he's
kind of disappeared I mean how is he
how's he dealing with what's happened to
him
um I believe he's doing great you know
he's still
you know dealing with um
with some people
trying to hold on to his money
um but for the most part I believe he's
um in a good space I think he's
you know learned a lot from this past
year and
you know hopefully he'll come out better
on the other side when he saw some of
the crazier things he was saying the
anti-semitic statements he was making
what did you feel as someone who knew
him well what did you feel about that
I felt that um if he was really
upset with specific people that
that the the message he was saying would
uh would kind of hijack what he's really
um
upset about you know and um
and you know that's that's kind of what
happened
um you just can't generalize you have to
be specific
especially if you're
um talking about
uh anybody any race of people you have
to be specific on who exactly you're
talking about
let's talk about the music industry huge
amount of attention being given to
artificial intelligence now yeah uh
clearly it has awesome power not least
to replicate how people like you would
make music what do you feel about that I
think it's terrible I think it's uh
it's gonna make people lazier uh less
creative
um
you know could you imagine if an actor
like if I decided not to do a sequel
and the movie company said we have
we have the rights to your likeness
right we're gonna put you in the secret
whether you want to be or not right we
have the right to so now they use AI to
put ice cube in a movie I don't want to
be in saying things I don't want to say
in doing things I wouldn't do so to me
that's terrible or or taking an artist
that's passed away and having them do a
new song
with lyrics that they may not agree with
um it's just you know we're just it's a
slippery slope that is will hurt us more
than it will help us is there a benefit
that you can see well you could use AI
to enhance what you do
um
I mean we use you know automation here
and there to
help advance and make us a sound better
but you know once you take the
paintbrush out of the painter's hand
is it really
a painting from him you know you turned
down a nine million dollar movie role in
2021 because you wouldn't take the covid
vaccines being mandated in Hollywood at
the time any regrets there's a lot of
money not at all no I won't regret you
know my thought when I heard that story
you must be even richer than I think you
are
I mean everybody can use nine million
dollars I don't care how rich they think
they are you know everybody can use that
money I could have used that money my
family could use that money but I felt
like you know your health
is worth more than all the money in the
world because if you had all the money
in the world and you wasn't healthy
you would you would use that money to
get healthy so
um to me it was an experimental drug
and um they had no time to really see
the long-term effects like most and I'm
vaccinated I've been vaccinated when I
was a kid but these are drugs that have
been tested for decades and you know
pretty much most of the side effects I
mean ultimately I felt about covert
vaccines that once it was established
against what they initially thought that
you could still transmit the virus
whether you were vaccinated or not to me
it becomes a personal choice then it's
down to you yeah without a doubt and you
know the pharmaceutical companies made a
lot of money
um
businesses close you know it was a it's
it's like an incentive
even when things are not going right to
keep going
um it's kind of like the war machine you
know if you make the bullets and the
Band-Aids you're gonna always want to be
in war because it's profitable if you
watch out are you going to vote for next
year no it's what we would call in
Britain the Hobson's choice
no what's that mean it means it doesn't
matter your matter which way you go
you're going to get screwed I mean Joe
Biden looks like he barely knows what
day it is Donald Trump might be in a
prison cell so if that's the choice what
does it say about America
um
that
you know America needs to
re-examine
where we are where we're going
who we wanted to lead us
and what kind of country we actually
want to be you know um
a lot of choices
you know I've become independent
and all this because I like to sit back
and see you know who's really gonna be
the best choice
um unfortunately the choices are not
um
always top-notch so have you thought of
running yourself oh I would never run it
might be a vacancy now can you nah
I don't want to be a politician you know
they can King me
King I'll be okay well actually I've
always felt if it hadn't been for King
George III being so useless you could
still have the monarchy here and it
could be king peers I mean right I could
share the phone with you yeah King peers
and King Cube
hey uh I think it's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying are
you telling me
all right I'll see I'll seed maniacal
power to King Cube okay thank you
appreciate it great to see you thank you
good to see you always pretty good
well that's cues big three basketball
tournament We'll Be Live at the O2 in
London this August you can watch the
full interview on the Piers Morgan and
censored YouTube page from right now on
Thursday next we're used to politicians
kissing babies on the campaign Trail but
not nibbling and sniffing them we'll
debate what on Earth Joe Biden has been
up to next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk London crawling
200 Eco protesters slow March through
the capital and the Prime Minister wants
to crack down on useless University
degrees and would you visit the pub
that's only showing women's sport that's
all coming up at nine
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to peers organizer and
welcome to tonight's Stellar fat talk to
your Visa Craig Adrian hello miss me of
course oh look at those faces ever ever
faces smiled saying yes but meant no
those are the phases um I want to show a
clip this is President Biden most
powerful man in the world the leader of
the Free World you know he always does
weird stuff these days right no look
what he does to this baby who he's never
met have a look at this
thank you
now this was taken in Helsinki when he
left the uh the summit last week before
he boarded Air Force One but it's so
weird Esther I think what man would do
that to a baby he's never met yeah I'm
not so I'm not usually I usually give
old people a pass because I you know
they're older and you have to respect
yourself he's nibbling but a strange
baby there was a bigger issue at hand
here which is he just keeps making more
and more gas everyone can see that he is
becoming a bit senile yeah and you know
the Democrats really need to take this
conversation seriously this man cannot
run for it I don't even I'm sorry I
don't think he'll be able to make it to
the next general election I mean to the
extent that he can still maintain his
mental faculties to even do that I
really all these images were showing him
before this is happening every week
defend the man I mean this isn't about
defending him this is about wait no this
is about querying why it's appropriate
to criticize someone for being kind to a
small human because that's what all he
was doing he
I don't think kind is the word I'd use
he's literally nibbling a baby shocked
and traumatized
problem with that but clearly the man is
losing the ability to take on social
well that's the biggest he's been
playful no that's fine and we can see
he's been playful because we've all been
there we're a small child
maybe I never heard the adults around
very funny you've all been there
focused
it would be if it was an isolation but
if you take it in the context of him
repeatedly falling over yes tripping on
Air Force One falling off bikes all the
verbal gases Relentless even saying God
saved the Queen the other day randomly
nine months after he attended her
funeral it's a it's a procession now a
verbal and physical gaps it's true what
we have is the Press reporting a
prescription I agree with you and I
wonder I wonder why we have this focus
is it because of his age is it because
yes we think that you're you just cannot
stand as a as a you cannot be taken
seriously it's not about his age well if
it's not about his age what is it
because I know people like Joan Collins
if you're 10 years older and have a half
they've seen half their age the problem
is not his age it's his condition well
he looks to me to be at a fairly
Advanced stage now of senility and he's
the man with his finger on the trigger
okay can we just okay and and what do we
get that information from that he looks
so my eyes and ears that's your own
personal view we're not being told no no
no it's a view shared by most people by
the medics that surround do you feel
comfortable that if he wins the next
election he'd be there for another four
years which is six years from now if
that's who the voters voting do you feel
comfortable the president of the United
States believe in democracy and that's
what happens peers
even if he's totally Gaga but Pierce who
is saying he's totally Gaga my eyes and
ears because you don't agree with
himself or I I don't believe
I did but by the way he was a republican
say that he's he's senile my dear we
heard this man all right you gotta move
on we're going to talk about it let's
move on to another age story so there
was a fantastic game at Wimbledon
yesterday yes alcaraz taking down uh
Djokovic or somebody put it I think it
was a time today the kid beats the goat
which I thought was great
um and it was a fantastic game obviously
but there was another talking point
which was this guy
oh yes who looked
unbelievably useful right he is 60 in
December yep right and yet he doesn't
look here right so we don't know why
maybe it's a wonder of of something
maybe it's natural maybe it's not who
knows in Hollywood but we thought we'd
have a little game which is uh pit the
younger or older right
well let me know I'm going to show you
some some pictures of people okay and
you've got to tell me whether they're
younger older than Brad wow okay
um I'm going to say younger but
definitely looks older I think they're
about the same age Boris Johnson is only
younger by six months than Brad Pitt
okay next
he's younger than Pitt by three months
it's in the neck really yeah he's
younger than Brad Pitt yeah he looks
about 20 years old okay next one
Governor Ron DeSantis I think he's
younger I think I think younger he's
younger by 16 years than Brad Pitt look
at that yeah
uh next one well I know Tom Cruise I
know he's older same age no he's a year
and a half older Cruise than Brad Pitt
and now probably the most difficult one
of all
actually that's a good question
um wow I mean this is same age
you have to be younger I was gonna say
he must be older than you yeah thank you
thank you Paula yeah thank you not
uh I am younger like a year and three
months apparently than Brad Pitt I gotta
say he looks good on it Brad Pitt I've
only met Brad Pitt uh once and it was at
the Oscars I was in the red carpet for
CNN and I shouted out Brad he arrived
late with Angelina when they were still
talking to each other and I've just got
a brilliant picture where somebody took
and his bread just going hey man like
that that's it that's my Brad Pitt
moment
um literally just said hey man uh but I
remembered it and it was a moving moment
um talk about well not another man let's
talk about a pyramid of white supremacy
the Church of England is defended
teaching controversial race theories
saying kids shouldn't wait until 18 to
learn about racial justice so teaching
guidance issued by the Diocese of Saint
edmundsbury and Ipswich it's the white
supremacy pyramid
at the bottom racial indifference and
jokes and at the top is mass murder the
suggestion being that if you don't get a
grip at your school early Esther you
become rapidly a white supremacist mass
murderer why has this been taught in our
schools honestly it's very baffling and
it's as if the church doesn't have there
aren't enough social ills to go around
they're not enough issues in society for
the church to address I grew up as an
Anglican and you know looking at many
Anglican churches in sub-Saharan African
Asia in particular looking at the church
of England what they're doing so the
religion is quite worrying I mean this
is really a non-issue and it has nothing
to do with the church of England I don't
understand why they need to choose
politically charged topics to to try and
I don't know further the cause of
British presumption Paula that it's a
bit like when they did the um the the
Gillette reboot and they ditched their
you know man supporting campaign and
basically made it out if you don't do
something you're all going to be Harvey
Weinstein it's that it's like why go to
these extremities of mass murderers if
you don't deal with your critical race
there serious school it's nonsense so I
don't I don't think it is that so
firstly it's not nonsense you've got 30
seconds well exactly and it's not
controversial it's called critical race
Theory remember this is something that
was born out of academics they were
lawyers they were discussing about
Justice and Injustice within
institutions not about not about
individuals and it's the church
attempting to teach about Injustice
that's really important
telling kids they're going to be Mass
murderers if they carry on I don't agree
with you and I don't agree with that's
what they're being taught peers gotta
leave it there uh we'll come back to
that issue uh good to see you uh cute
whatever you're up to keep it on sense
that's all for me tonight good night see
you tomorrow
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]